ganz kurz übrigens diesen bei der orange
aber ihre beine sind braun von der aber
das gesicht des orange und der arbeits
auch orange meine sehr verehrten damen
und herren seit dem letzten video sind
einige tage vergangen und wir alle
wissen dass unser lieblings
youtube-kanal natürlich sehr regelmäßig
hoch es deswegen bei max gibt der sich
im april schrauber in einer also baut
aber es auch neue case die hat hier
sollte schon mal helfen wir folgen ganz
kurz bevor wir anfangen zwei dinge leute
ihr habt vielleicht gemerkt meine letzte
generation wurde runtergenommen rtl2 hat
gesagt moment mal der reagiert auf unser
video und nur das wollen wir nicht viel
sperren das video weltweit dazu an der
stelle eine kurze nachricht an rtl2 und
das ist gar nicht böse gemeint gegenüber
anderen youtube an aber er hat
vielleicht auch gesehen bei luca kam
auch action und runter lukas video haben
die sogar kommentiert und ihm die rolle
angeboten in der sendung und bei mir
sperren sie das video
es kann gut sein das weiß ich ehrlich
gesagt nicht ob das vielleicht
automatisch war und die gar nicht
bewusst sich entschieden haben wir
gespannt das video und der laus bei
anderen youtube an aber ich glaube ist
auch für hilft mir gar nicht schlecht
wenn sie leute darauf reagieren so kommt
hilft mir so richtig in diese youtube
community rhein und die kriegen wir auch
bei zu kartoffeln folgen wir haben
lustige videos also rtl 2 just relax
chair und jetzt kann ich schon mal sagen
um welche folge sich das heutige video
drehte und zwar geht es somit fame um
jeden preis mein kind muss berühmt
werden ist schon eine woche alt aber der
titel erst mal nicht übergangen werden
ich habe mir ganz viel sein das video
leider zeit die beschreibung werden das
hat er mir gesagt achte bei diesen
beschreibungstext die beschreibung vor
der rtl2 selbst für hilft mir die
ratgeberserie zeit geschichten von
jungen menschen die mit finanziellen
problemen liebeskummer stress in der
schule oder mit eltern zu kämpfen haben
jede folge von hilft mir beschreibt ein
problem wie es nicht er im leben eines
teenagers passieren könnte die experten
der ratgeber serie analysieren die
konfliktsituation der jugend
ein und geben wertvolle ratschläge zur
krisenbewältigung wir schauen mal kurz
wir schauen wir kurz über die videos
darüber natürlich ein klassisches
teenager problem ist man will seinen
lehrer für sind wir ehrlich die ja du
hast wirst du fahren wir mal und zum
abschluss muss man natürlich auch zwei
videos erwähnen an dieser stelle wir
alle kennen das klassische problem von
teenagern dass man 35 jahre alt ist und
denkt man ist ein achtjähriges mädchen
und natürlich dass man mit 18 jahren
glauben dass ich gerne den arm operieren
lassen möchte um die kim kardashian
auszusehen und dabei an einem pädophilen
und perversionen gerät ist auch eine
sache die einfach jeden teenager
betrifft genau alles klar fangen wir mit
der folge jasmin ist mit ihrer
sechsjährigen tochter beim tanztraining
privatstunden für 320 euro im monat so
dass die sechsjährige und hier haben wir
einen christbaum frage setzt die mutter
gesetzlich mal mit dynamite genauso
hätte könntest du uns kurz bedient
schaut bei der unterwäsche zeigen sie
will aus ihrer tochter mir einen großen
star machen um jeden preis so wir sagen
dass wir wehren uns gar nicht wirklich
aber lustig gemacht das ist echt ein
problem das es auf gibt das so eltern
richtig druck auf ihre kinder machen und
sagen entweder du wirst youtuber oder du
bist nicht meine person jeder kann ich
diese eltern oder dieses outfit ist aber
ich weiß auch nicht also dies auch
irgendwie orange das denn somit gleich
einen grünen strikt ab und das ist ja
nicht weil es das kamera bilder sieht
diese mir das ist der weg nach allen
gemein haut und ihre mutter ist einfach
abgemacht stunde sind auch schon rum da
kannst du dich eigentlich hingehen ja ja
ja bei ihren auf das mädchen sechs jahre
alter porsche daher was hat die gewesen
im gesicht alter aber das ding ist die
sind so lange das müssen eigentlich fake
lashes sein ich bin ministerium einen
vergleich es noch einmal täuscht wenn
wir etwas schon üblich ist im land der
roten menschen auf diese sekte das ist
wichtig weil sie wissen ist eine
renommierte schule ist richtig so kalt
wie sie ja ich musste mir dann von der
schule verweisen und bei ihrem talent
was wirklich schade
er weiß woran ich das erinnert mal kurz
augen zeigt jetzt bilder weil das nicht
sogar frage sich wohl so sollen diesen
service sondern laut brechen aber auch
dort machte koch cdu so jemand hat
überzeugt dass wirklich was mit der
überweisung schieben nenne ich möchte
ganz große 10 10 12
ich dachte mir da etwas falsch mache als
york jetzt aber die hat wirklich
irgendwie 6 oder sie zumindest sehr
breiten fuße aus
die zeit spielt erzählt er dass dieses
10 www bmz das baby sechs passiert dann
irgendwann bestimmt wo hier zu sein
ja ich bin auch froh und sich mit ihr
über die belastungen von mir reden -
bezahlt werden müssen
320 euro für die tanzschule tanzschule
gesagt ab 320 euro für die tanzschule
für die tanzschule geschickt unsere
tochter in die tanzschule der gast gegen
baumann diese welt junger bemerkst jetzt
die verbindung die mutter sieht aus wie
ein weihnachtsbaum die tochter wird in
die tannen schule geschickt
deswegen ist ja auch grün dies in
wirklichkeit einfach ein gewächs
wir haben über 600 euro miete pro monat
wir haben einen kreditvertrag und wir
haben die leasingraten für das auto das
mir erstmal weit bringen würden dass man
sie feiern muss das mag ja alles sein
aber wir müssen auch noch von irgendwas
leben essen und trinken ganz kurz ich
sehe es ganz gut ich habe es keinen
wirklich als job gesagt so setzt sich
mal so hin dass man eine unterwäsche
lädt carmen alter ich will nicht mehr
hinschauen ich will ich meine
aufmerksamkeit darauf lenken tanzstunden
ich kann das nicht bezahlen da musst du
dir einen nebenjob suchen und auch geld
dazuverdienen ich soll mir ist noch
einen nebenjob suchen ich muss mit dem
kind auf den tanzstunden hingehen
hat zu reden also ja da kann man einfach
kein doppler aus wenn du musst mit dem
kind zu den tanzstunden hier integer das
320 euro sind definitiv zu viel
die möglichkeit gehabt meine eltern
dieses geld gehabt vielleicht auf
geschafft groß rauszukommen aber ihr
habt das geld ja nicht hatte doch gerade
gesagt also für den sport kommen zwei
nieren es irgendwie klappt irgendwie so
ein humanoid das verschafft mir den die
er davon zwar geht es um dein enkel in
die wollte fragen ob du hier vielleicht
400 euro leihen könnte wollte dister
welt hat ja ich muss halt gerade werde
könnte die bord schicken ihre mutter der
14 mal getroffen
damit feiert er hat gefragt zugleich
alle millionen geben kannst hat er
wirklich der wahrheit nicht korrekt also
ist es geht nicht um dich gesagt alles
klar was will mir ja mit 400 euro fährt
sich auf klassenfahrt vielleicht ja
richtig ja genau
ganz kurz übrigens mit diesen beiden
orange aber ihre weine sind braun von
ein ja aber das gesicht des orange und
der arbeit auch orange mit 400 euro
was will ich mit einer million euro ist
vielleicht seine mutter und seine
komplette familie selbst erkannten wer
braucht es um die behandlung zu bezahlen
ja ja ja ja das ist immer das beste an
der schule in dem alter finde ich für
mich das natürlich gerne mit wenn man
dann als kind nicht mitreden kann oder
so dann wird man schnell ausgeschlossen
kleine moment ganz kurzen man weiß
einfach schon was jetzt passiert wir
sind in diesem schlafzimmer und dieser
blick von der pforte gesagt was in
dieser folge passiert
bei zu hilfe erfolgen gehört natürlich
klassische teenager problem aber auch
dass jeweils die geldbörsen
es muss einmal jeder profi 400 hast du
gesagt aber ganz kurz die bewertung
sinkt 2006 2400 das sagen viele leute
haben sich daher wieder erkannt dass
ihre mutter geld grün ist dass sie sechs
jahre alt sind und von ihrer mutter zum
tanzunterricht gezwungen werden der
klassiker so an der stelle muss ich kurz
aus erklären was aber zu lange gedauert
hätte das im video zu zeigen und zwar
sondern dieser tanzschule in casting
stattfinden wo für irgendeine
fernsehwerbung oder so irgendwelche
tänzer gesucht werden also die gut
tanzen können und dieses casting ist
jetzt ganz ganz wichtig in der folge
zwar also ich will ich will wirklich
nicht deiner erziehung reinreden aber
sollte man sechsjährigen kindern cola
geben
ich habe es ist keine gute idee aber die
garantieren damit ist diese töpfe
verwaltet die kampagne wandtattoo ist an
der wand und damit ist alles gesagt wenn
diese frau wenn wir nicht wissen muss
mir sagen oder vielleicht betrunken so
wie sie spricht
hast du wieder mal eine mundspülung
getrunken
mama hast schon wieder frostschutz
gedruckt mit mama club heilige ist kein
getränk und ja leute wie sie jetzt an
dem punkt angekommen wie auch bei der
letzten hilfen erfolge und zwar habe ich
jetzt immer noch 40 minuten rohmaterial
deswegen will ich sagen was sie beim
letzten mal und hier stimmt einfach in
den kommentaren ab ob ihr ein zweiter
teil haben wollte ich es mir die
kommentare genau durch verteidiger
aktuellen 14 datei und warum und um die
zeit zu überbrücken bis der zweite teil
kommt habe ich jetzt für euch ein paar
bessere szenen aus einer nagelneuen
folge was das geht mir und welt ist
wieder deutsch habt ihr da so ein
partner wieder drauf gekommen der
direkte verfolger täglich danach würde
mich freuen und macht gute leute heute
wird elektrisch
[Applaus]
[Musik]